what's going on guys today we're going
to be examining the leaked panels
from chapter 284 of my hero academia
this chapter very much has the vibes
from that overhaul fight back in season
four
only this time this takes it even higher
because shiguraki
is literally the devil himself make sure
you sub to the channel as i'll be doing
a more detailed breakdown of the
official chapter
when it comes out later this week okay
so
thankfully this chapter picks up
immediately where the last one left off
with deku floating in the sky and
holding all the heroes with black whip
in his left arm
and then using his right arm to you know
pull shiguraki towards him using black
whip
the panel then zooms out to show us just
how high these guys are in the air
and i'm telling you it's ridiculously
high like you could probably
do a skydive from this kind of height if
i was someone in this situation like
manual who just has no flight abilities
whatsoever i would be
bricking it i would be so scared thanks
to deku's float quirk though
everyone is maintained in the air no
one's falling back to earth just yet
and we get this line from shigaraki in
which he says to deku
that if he loves the sky so much he'll
send deku to heaven
alongside gran torino after he steals
one for all
the disrespect from shiguraki this whole
arc
every week he just takes it to a new
level you know
midoriya replies saying that he won't
let shiguraki hurt anyone else
and we get a cool flashback sequence in
which we see you know deku in the ua gym
and they've assembled a few different
students to help him master his new
abilities
specifically we're talking about cerro
ochaco and froppy
and they're like what do you want us to
do exactly
deku tells them that he's been training
with bakago but throughout their
exercises he's never been able to catch
back ago using blackwhip
this interaction is really important
because like i said
deku in the last chapter captured
shigeraki using black whip
so the fact that back then he wasn't
even able to capture
you know a fellow student in bakugou and
now he's capturing a devil who defeated
all those pro heroes
you know that's a pretty big improvement
so credit to sarah for helping deku
level up in that way
interestingly there's another panel of
deku and ochako
floating together in the gym and she
kind of like shows him how to balance in
the air
and then use his air force to propel
himself forward while floating
in this moment it's clear that ochako is
the one making him float
so it's sort of like practice for the
future power that he knows he's going to
get
but you know it's unlikely that she
knows anything about float
i guess this moment explains why all
might was so sure
that the next power deku would unlock
would be float
because he envisioned that deko and
achako would practice together
and then eventually midoriya would just
activate float naturally sometime
after that almight and bakugo then sit
together
and have a pretty chill conversation
whilst they watch what's going on
and it appears that bakago mentioned
something that made me really suspicious
according to the rough translations all
might made detailed notes on the fifth
sixth and seventh users of one for all
but for some reason the fourth user
he just crossed it out like he crossed
out all the valuable information
about that person about their quirk and
their death bakago himself even
questions it he's like
why are you hiding this why did you
cross off the fourth user of one for all
i have a few thoughts on why this could
be most of which i'm gonna save for my
official review of this chapter when i
see the official translations
but for now what i'll say is that all
might would only cross this out if he's
trying to protect
deku and bakugou so clearly there's some
information there that is just
really sensitive and they just can't
know what it is
for those that don't know the fourth is
this guy right here
and we know he is the fourth because in
a previous chapter
we saw him passing one for all to the
fifth user so he is the fourth user
anyway moving on from that according to
nav on twitter
bakugou remarks how deku always thinks
about others
and how that's just something he
personally has never understood
which is why he bullied midoriya almight
then says
that maybe by helping deku harness his
new quirks like he's been doing
bakago is somehow trying to atone for
what he's done in the past
if that's true then that would be some
really nice character growth from bakago
you know
growing out of his old shell and kind of
turning into a true
friend and rival to deku i think we've
we've gradually been seeing that happen
but for all might to say it out loud and
for baccago not to deny it i think this
is a really good sign
the chapter then ends back in the
present day with deku and shiguraki just
coming towards each other at high speed
and shiguraki's hand is outstretched at
this moment and he's ready to steal one
for all and decay deku like he said
however midoriya kicks shigaraki square
in the stomach and flies past him
deku thinks to himself that even though
shiguraki can handle 100
he's healing slower than before and he's
taking damage
even with super regeneration midoriya
ponders
how one fraul is the power specifically
created
to stop all for one and that he has to
destroy all for one right now
regardless of what happens to him this
thought process ties into what bakugou
was saying in the flashback
about how deku only cares about you know
helping other people
and doesn't really stop to think about
himself as surprising as it is to say
in these final panels it almost looks
like shiguraki is afraid of deku
and we see that midoriya uses his float
quirk to maneuver in the air
before then flying towards shigaraki and
delivering
yet another overhaul style beatdown and
uh yeah
maybe shiguraki might be unconscious or
something that's a possibility
but for this chapter at least it looks
like the heroes have gotten the win
which is
all we can ask for but yeah it's not
gonna last
like i said be sure to subscribe to the
channel as i'll be doing a breakdown of
the official chapter
when that's released but until then
peace out